mais d'abord que se passe-t-il derrière
les murs du foyer de vie Anaïs à La
Membrolle-sur-Choisille un éducateur de
54 ans a mis fin à ses jours au sein
même de la structure il y a une semaine
dans un mail envoyé avant sa mort il
dénonce le harcèlement de sa direction
un fait qu'il n'est pas isolé puisqu'il
s'agit du deuxième suicide au sein des
salariés en mai 2020 l'un de ses
collègues c'était déjà donné la mort par
armes à feu le point avec Romain
Delville et Faustine Luneau
mardi 13 juin dans les locaux du foyer
de vie de la Fondation Anaïs à La
Membrolle-sur-Choisille il est peu avant
9h quand trois salariés découvrent le
corps sans vie d'un de leurs collègues
cette éducateur spécialisée à l'accueil
de jour 37 ans d'expérience vient de se
suicider à l'arme à feu nous avons fait
appel à l'unité mobile rattaché au pour
l'ensemble des salariés et au moment
d'ailleurs où je vous parle il y a un
deuxième débrief qui se déroule sur la
structure avec les salariés et puis un
soutien pour les personnes accueillies
les personnes porteuses handicap
qui est suivi par nos psychologues de
l'établissement sauf que l'homme de 54
ans a on parallèle programmé un mail
envoyé à tous ces collègues dans lequel
il accuse des membres de la direction de
la voir poussée à l'irréparable certains
veulent bien témoigner mais par crainte
des représailles ont demandé l'anonymat
et donner beaucoup de sa personne par
rapport aux résidents par rapport à nos
collègues aussi si on avait besoin il
était là peu importe les leurs peu
importe il était présent dans nos
réunions il a on pouvait avoir sa parole
il était là aussi pour nous aider
c'est un professionnel hors pair en fait
il y a pas de mots il était
il méritait pas cette humiliation venant
de la direction
là
[Musique]
et puis voilà puis après bah après coup
en fait c'est donc voilà beaucoup de
tristesse beaucoup de colère aussi
vraiment ça se transforme vraiment en
colère
de de voir que ça arrive en fait là de
notre cercle proche en fait trois ans
après le suicide d'un chef de service de
la structure les salariés dénonce des
conditions de travail qui confie nos
harcèlement il y a une non
reconnaissance de notre travail et
un climat de confiance inexistant envers
les équipes ce qui fait que nous sommes
en totale insécurité une enquête a été
ouverte et confiée à la gendarmerie qui
devra déterminer si le management a mené
cette éducateur chevronné à se suicider
sur son lieu de travail